salon nautique a ouvert ses portes à
paris et cela jusqu'au 13 décembre
on y trouve toutes les nouveautés et
cela va du pédalo aux yachts de luxe
pour les amateurs petite visite avec
julien beaumont et eric de lannion la
folie des grandeurs jamais le salon
nautique n'avait présenté autant de
grandes unités des bateaux luxueux pour
faire oublier la crise
en moyenne les ventes ont été réduites
de 50% cette année mais les chantiers
depuis quelques mois voir revenir les
clients fait profonde allait clairement
derrière nous les salons d'automne de la
rentrée le prouve
et maintenant on vient chercher la
confirmation à paris dans ce contexte un
mot d'ordre clair boiseries en acajou
chrome disséminés sur le pont tech à
profusion mais aussi du carbone pour
gagner du poids
exemple sur ce voilier de 12 mètres
conçue uniquement pour des sorties à la
journée
je crois qu'il ya une recherche
d'originalité ne pas avoir le bateau de
tout le monde d'avoir quelque part
un bateau qui ressort un petit peu de
la basse un salon de la grande bleue qui
pensent vers motorisation hybride ou
électrique pile à combustible
mais aussi des idées toutes simples ce
catamaran est équipé pour récupérer les
eaux de pluie selon vient ici dans cette
gouttière et là nous avons deux
solutions soit repart à la mer soit on a
un système de testeurs qui permet de
vérifier la salinité et la propreté
avant qu'elle aille dans les réservoirs
donc on sait qu'on a de l'eau pure
depuis qui va descendre dans les
réservoirs et sur un grain tropicale
entre la grand voile et la surface du
pont peut récupérer entre 2 et 4 100
litres d'eau en une averse des
innovations qui profite aussi à des
bateaux plus petits
83 mille euros pour ce voilier de 10
mètres à bord boisclair et de nombreuses
ouvertures comme sur les grands un deux
pièces avec vue sur mer future star des
sapins de marins et tout de suite la
partie